hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
oh what a [ __ ] sack that's a forward
pass to a [ __ ] lineman as far as I
know I'm alone in New York alone in New
York got your head in the oven alone in
New York you feeling no love in I'm
watching James Madison vs Stony Brook
the rank 2 and 24th and I don't know
what division there's 52 seconds left
it's 38:35 this is what you do on a
rainy [ __ ] 3rd I can't believe how
much it [ __ ] rains here in New York I
never remember that [ __ ] you got to feel
the Pranay don't feel the pressure
Division two it's goddamn problem it's
actually Wednesday when I'm recording
this Wednesday afternoon and this is it
right here fourth and 14 he fades back
to pass he throws the [ __ ] ball give
it to him 16 seconds to go the clock has
stopped they're still running up to the
line just in case you missed out on the
exciting end to James Madison versus
Stony Brook D just down the [ __ ] ball
and the clock wasn't even moving a
little home cooking their little pet a
home cooking yeah if I get rained on
Monday
it rained today Wednesday all goddamn
day and I don't have any I don't mean
rain gear cuz I'm a big Hollywood phony
and I live out in the desert out there
and lost honglei's so I know I was
[ __ ] annoying it's beautiful
beautiful love lush landscaping back
here landscaping landscape back here in
the East Coast all right here's the
final play once again in the shotgun
number four fades back to pass wide
[ __ ] open right down to see Mike down
at the 29 yard line there's nine seconds
left the clock is to keep stopping what
is this does it stop under two minutes
the referees got his hand on the
[ __ ] head and he hikes Bonnie [ __ ]
spikes it no time went off the clock
I've never seen that before in my life
somehow this guy spiked the ball in less
than any time that could be registered
nine seconds left they got a shot at the
end zone see I'm telling you right now
you guys have sleeping sleeping on
Division two oh god here this guy coming
in he's got a [ __ ] tattoo array would
you look at that these goddamn kids
today these guys lining up well what the
[ __ ] yard line were they on 30 plus 10
plus 8 48 yard a boom right down the
center that's a tie [ __ ] score
everybody more Division 2 action coming
at you days after the game happened here
on the [ __ ] Monday morning pot I'm in
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning all the happy
grandfather's in the stands there was
all the white people and you never threw
the ball you did the old razzle-dazzle
speaking of which your New York Yankees
have advanced through the to the ALCS
and heir awaiting the winner of the
Houston Astros in the Tampa Bay
Lightning Tampa Bay Devil Rays Tampa Bay
Rays we don't offend anybody
down there in Florida I don't want no
devil in my team even though I fed my
ex-wife to a gator I don't need no devil
in the national pastime team name look
at this this all [ __ ] up this division
is the field goal kicker is number 50
he's got a linebacker number and he gets
hugged by a lineman who's 55 doesn't
make any sense
cheerleaders with division to dance
moves
I mean the whole thing it's just really
that just really is a hierarchy I tell
you when you can see the tree line over
your [ __ ] bleachers that's when you
know not not the NFL dreams over I'm not
even saying that you have you got some
more steps to take
I actually love these [ __ ] stadiums
little ass teams you know the one we you
know somebody got up behind you to walk
up to the bathroom cuz you just hear the
sound of aluminum siding being stepped
on as they climb up the [ __ ] stairs
they go with an onside kick everybody
which is handled by number 90 he was
either a wide receiver or a [ __ ]
lineman bumps into his own guy a little
skip step and he goes down and that'll
be the end of regulation
James Madison action I'm buying for this
job right now I want to sit in on one of
these games and do some color commentary
throwing that out there right now as
long as I get two free tickets to the
[ __ ] game well I guess I'll be
commentating I'll be sitting right in
the announcer's booth right anyway we're
waiting I am as a baseball fan I am
awaiting the matchup that I was that I
said was going to be there way back way
back when the Red Sox made their last
attempt to get past to catch up with the
Yankees and they couldn't do it this
year
boohoo to me right what are they gonna
win it every [ __ ] year I'll give a
[ __ ] alright I just want to see some
great baseball so I wanted to see the
Yankees versus the Astros right the
Astros were up two games to none just
like the New York Yankees but unlike the
New York Yankees the Astros did not
finish off the Tampa Bay former Devil
Rays now the Rays possibly the future
Montreal Expo Devil Rays Gossett jr.
whatever the [ __ ] they're going to call
them they lost Game three all right
whatever what are you gonna do let's
come back you know Game four and win it
and they lost Game four convincingly
both games so now they now it's do or
[ __ ] die they're going back to
Houston extra plane ride as the Yankees
rest so now I was sitting there going I
was sitting there thinking you know with
no baseball knowledge whatsoever that
you know considering Houston won at two
years ago and last year came damn close
to get I don't know we did all right
against them but I thought they were a
real tough team and they would probably
pissed that they lost to us that they
were gonna come out with some fire here
in the playoffs playoffs bye
and that they were gonna face off
against the Yankee's and I felt that I
was gonna see an epic series that
goddamn accused it don't don't make
don't make a [ __ ] liar out of me here
I don't I don't give a [ __ ] don't if the
the Rays the holy rays if they went okay
I just want to see a great [ __ ]
series
I love October baseball and I think the
winner is coming out of the [ __ ]
American American League unless the
Astros and Yankees both choked meaning
the devil race [ __ ] go to the World
Series then I feel like but you never
know about st. Louis st. Louis is always
in there
I don't know anybody on any team I'm
just going by in the past history they
always seemed to [ __ ] win one every
few years they're actually number two
all-time with ten I think ten World
Series championships I basically don't
have any stats to back up anything that
I just said all right so I'm gonna watch
the game I watched the the end of the
the Yankees the clincher I watched it in
this bar and this [ __ ] I walked in
the bar there was like nobody there
right which was always great but there
was four people two Twins fans and two
Yankee fans making enough noise for a
crowded bar and I don't know why they
didn't get thrown out I'm just assuming
that it was because it was such a light
night anybody in there spending money
was welcome and absolutely just [ __ ]
screaming at each other screaming let's
go Yankees like sitting right next to
each other just scream and the twins
face fans were like wait lately older
than me screaming that loud so I go in
there and all I get my little [ __ ]
club soda sitting her buddy and we're
watching it I was just [ __ ] laughing
our asses off and when the Yankees
poured it on in the end you just put the
game away and they were panning to all
the sad twin fans in the crowd this
[ __ ] Yankee fan was going
see it you really hate to see it [ __ ]
dying laughing he was being such a
[ __ ] dick it was it was hilarious and
then then he started thrashing Tom Brady
which I also thought was [ __ ] funny I
don't know why I guess you know cuz they
went it all the [ __ ] time I don't
know he started making [ __ ] Tom fun
to Tom Brady so hilarious and whatever
we watching the end of the game then all
of a sudden there was like this
commotion and the bouncers came in and
they was I don't want to which guy I
think they were throwing the Yankee guy
out he finally just screamed too much or
I think the Twins fans got mad that they
realized that they were finally gonna
lose and the inevitable happened what
you knew was gonna happen what I knew
was gonna happen the second I walked in
here like this is gonna go sideways at
some point right so the [ __ ] guy gets
dragged out and as usual that the
dumbest thing you can do is argue with
the bouncer once he puts his hands on
you you're going out the door so just
help him walk along just be like sorry I
know I'm an idiot you know whatever no
resistance and just get the [ __ ] out of
there you know intact but this guy
doesn't do that you know and you hate to
see it so he gets manhandled out the
[ __ ] door you know you know bouncers
are once you start manhandling they make
sure you touch both sides of the door
jam the [ __ ] door you know maybe the
door handle to the kidney right so he
[ __ ] gets taken out like a Christmas
tree that's still on its stand basically
right spill in the water the whole way
out right so then he's out there and
what I looked at my watch I was like
holy [ __ ] it's [ __ ] so it's 20 to
1:00 in the morning I thought it was
like 11:30 I get the [ __ ] out of here
these games take forever I got to do
some [ __ ] press the next morning so
I'm walking out of there and that
[ __ ] drunk jackass is arguing with
the bouncer like he's gonna at some
point be like ah you know what you know
what you're right I I didn't look at it
that way come back in the bar and
continue to stream and antagonize other
patrons right so he's yelling at the guy
and as I walk out he looks at me and in
mid argument he just goes Oh built bar I
love you stuff and then he just leaves
the bouncer it starts following me and
my buddy up the street hey Bill okay I
get picture just like [ __ ] away from me
you're [ __ ] drunk he was sober
absolutely but you're out of your
[ __ ] mind he's going yelling all my
catchphrases and he actually had me
laughing I swear to God if he threw one
more out I'd already cross the street he
threw one more on I would have stopped
because he was really making me laugh
but there's just nothing worse than a
[ __ ] guy you know hammered that wants
to take a picture with you it's just the
[ __ ] worst thinking now what does
that mean it's over James Madison you
know March down half a field however
they do it in overtime when they just
scored a touchdown so it's 45 that's not
over okay it's gonna say you got to give
Stony Brook they got the [ __ ] stones
over here now they get the ball to
25-yard line
and they needed touchdown to go ahead so
anyway he followed me for like [ __ ]
two blocks on the opposite side of the
street I was gone jesus [ __ ] christ I
don't see this guy know what [ __ ]
hotel I'm staying I don't need this [ __ ]
right and then finally he ducked into a
goddamn deli and I was like great and it
ended but uh if he wasn't so shit-faced
I would have taken a picture but I don't
know I don't subscribe to that he's a
feared you all in the picture not if
he's shit-faced it's gonna come up and
scream in my ear breathe all over me and
then hold up his inevitable like cell
phone that looks like it was [ __ ]
stabbed with the goddamn harpoon and
he's gonna accidentally have it on video
that I'm sorry and he's gonna breathe oh
I draw the line at that now that I'm
sober I'm gonna look down my nose at
drunk people don't you know what you're
doing to yourself
I don't know but that's why I like
alcohol cuz it is social cuz back in the
day I would have been drunk too and I
would have taken a picture with them
probably handed the phone to the bouncer
because that would have been funny to me
but now the more mature Hollywood bill
ain't doing it anyway I think the real
reason I was [ __ ] tired just [ __ ]
old
my body's falling apart I was past the
goddamn witching hour I don't know what
the hell happened to me any who the [ __ ]
is looking Stoneybrook throws it up for
grabs and nothing now it's third and ten
James Madison with the great pass rush
on third on second second and overtime
whatever the [ __ ] they call it all right
let me let me get to my [ __ ] Google
News people evidently like when I
[ __ ] read the news I'm that's still
Wednesday as I mentioned I'm going to
the I'm going to the [ __ ] stand
tonight
gonna do a little bit of stand-up as I
get ready before I'm gonna do my gigs
and uh was it Asheville Thursday night
and Friday night this week
Jesus Christ can you [ __ ] block
somebody third and 10 Stony Brook takes
a [ __ ] brutal stat sack Wow one more
play fourth in [ __ ] 18 I don't know
who that number 7 is but Jesus Christ
he's in on every goddamn play all right
I'm gonna be down there working on my
[ __ ] making sure I'm funny the next two
[ __ ] nights down there south and the
mason-dixon line I want to thank
everybody let me come on their podcast
and [ __ ] and let me all 5 damn it that
was a tough catch [ __ ] in and out of the
hands
Jesus Christ Stoneybrook acting like
they just won the goddamn [ __ ]
Superbowl they did win in overtime right
great game though huh
great I know I know I just painted a
picture I want to thank everybody at
barstool sports Dan cats store show KFC
I find it history hyenas with Yanis
Papas and Chris DiStefano
I had a [ __ ] great time those two
monster comedians you got to go out and
go see them despite oh you got to catch
that [ __ ] ball
despite what Yanis Pappas predicts for
the stand up future you know he's a
bright young man he thinks too much he
thinks too much he looks at the tea
leaves and I don't know I don't know
what happens I had a great time with
both of them that's definitely gonna be
a regular stop all of those shows I had
a great time and then I also did DZ's in
Mara which I didn't even know they moved
over to Showtime I thought they were
still on Vice they're on Showtime had a
great time with them and then I did
Bobby Kelly it was his birthday you guys
can watch it Bobby had all his friends
coming by during the whole podcast Bobby
got nothing but gifts and we sang happy
birthday like three times I didn't think
he was going to be podcasting I figured
it was his day off you know be to have
an ice-cream cake somewhere with this
family and then that was going to be it
but Bob is such a professional okay the
show must go on he even works on his
birthday
Colin Quinn showed up like halfway
through the podcast with some Joe's
pizza and I I think I ate more than the
birthday boy which is ridiculously rude
but I don't get good pizza you know out
on the west coast and then there was
some giant [ __ ] cookies that look
like they would bricks of lava and I
took one bite out of it and my body's
initial reaction was please don't do
that again
but then the sugar got in my [ __ ]
veins it was like you had you need to
hit that [ __ ] and I just kept [ __ ]
eating it it was like just imagine a
stack of bathroom tiles you know those
classic square wants it was probably as
thick as
eight of those and I think I'm still
feeling the goddamn effects I just can't
do what I used to do sorting these
Patriots versus Johnson a little bad I
know the Giants are doing well but I
think sake Quan Barclay if he gets past
our front four and he gets into our
secondary I think he's going to have a
good time running around I'm worried
about that man as far as their
quarterback he's too young to deal with
Bill Belichick Tom Coughlin isn't there
Eli's on the bench I think maybe we get
our second victory against the Giants
during the Eloi era maybe that happens
tonight I have no idea but I will tell
you this Washington had a great pass
rush against us and historically
speaking the Giants always have a great
defense although virzi was telling me
that the secondary is leave something to
be desired as my mom would say so we
shall see I'm gonna be doing a show
during the game but I'm going to try to
have it I'm going to try to have it on
Patriots just a light light light
schedule so far I don't think I'm really
gonna know who the [ __ ] this team is
until we play Kansas City you know
feasting on these [ __ ] and what
happened to parody is the parody this
year that everybody sucks anyway I'm
being a dick I'm sorry let's take a
break here we'll do read a little bit of
advertising here on the podcast I don't
even have the advertising yet 19 minutes
in I'll just remember to drop it in
there and we're back oh what a read I
think I just did so anyway I don't have
enough [ __ ] to do today which is [ __ ]
great I got up and I've been studying
this goddamn [ __ ] for my instrument that
I've been telling you about breaking out
the old East 6b from my
in ground school I actually love that
thing now I hated it all of these little
[ __ ] II [ __ ] things I'm like I'm
gonna figure you out
and I just with my instructor the book
YouTube I just [ __ ] I just you know
I'm under no pressure to get this
[ __ ] done under any so I guess I got
to do it by the end of the year also the
test changed changes a little bit I
don't give a [ __ ] though
well why would you want to blow through
this I want to understand it right so I
was having a hell of a time with the
[ __ ] at HSI right your horizontal
situation indicator when it reversed is
figuring out where the [ __ ] I would be
when they were showing it on the on the
map I get it now in that I can read it
correctly but I still don't quite get
how it lines up with the asmath how the
whole [ __ ] thing is switched where I
think I'm north but I'm south or east to
west the whole thing is [ __ ] weird
but it's going pretty good you know I
definitely get you know it definitely
starts to feel like math class when I
was just like ah [ __ ] let's just make
the class laugh get a [ __ ] failing
grade and I'll hang out with the class
clowns over the summer time which was a
great thing to do as a class clown you
know cuz if you just made your class
laugh during the regular like part of
the year you would use sort of a big
fish in a little pond you know what I
mean but all of a sudden when you went
to summer school it was just nothing but
class clown so in order to [ __ ] hold
your own you needed a certain confidence
level and you had to up your game and I
don't know I probably learned I probably
learned more about comedy going to
summer school then I did anywhere else
other than just becoming a [ __ ]
comedian the not giving a [ __ ] level we
tried to capture some of that on f is
for family I don't know whether we did
or not but yeah we definitely try to
because it's weird it's just like going
to jail we just become a better thief
you go to summer school you just become
a better class clown that's
you know you see new levels of
disrespect to teachers by the way did
anybody see those [ __ ] Yale kids I
don't know what happen this chick is all
upset she's one of 500 kids and she's
all mad I couldn't get past the part
where she was mad that the guy didn't
know what no her name
I need a [ __ ] teacher one time in
high school he didn't have 500 [ __ ]
kids he had like I don't even know what
he had he had like 20 kids per class he
taught like [ __ ] six classes he had
120 kids I had him two years two out of
four years in high school he called on
me once freshman year and then once
halfway through my junior year and he
called me by the wrong name and the
class thought it was funny and so did he
I didn't try to corner him outside to be
like hey man how come you don't know my
name snapping my fingers you have to
[ __ ] see this it I can't tell if it's
a comedy sketch a zombie movie I don't
know what the [ __ ] it is but they were
all coming off like they were in like
the Manson Family and the guys trying to
be a good guy he's answering he's he's
literally just he's validating every
[ __ ] thing that they're saying and as
he sayd and all the students are like
cocking their heads you know like you
know in gym room does that like what did
you say right that they're doing that
the whole time I couldn't want I just
want what the what happened where that
can't guy can't be like shut the [ __ ] up
you're one of five hundred get over it I
don't know why I got through five
minutes of it's like a half hour long if
you want to watch it I'll [ __ ] repost
it I don't even know what is going on
it's like it's like you guys you live in
America and you're going to Yale you're
crushing it I mean I find somebody who's
doing better than you well what are you
going do somebody with a Ponzi scheme
down on Wall Street boohoo you're not
making as much money as that guy you go
to Yale the Yale Bowl it's the first but
everybody that's where it all started
college football
design of the stadium what is the
problem I just don't feel like you know
if you don't know my name then and every
complaint was just it was just coming
that you know what the biggest problem
is what is affecting me right now the
whole thing I don't know I don't know
what I probably should shut up about it
but just watching this guy being totally
[ __ ] courteous answering the thing no
matter what he said it was like no [ __ ]
you
we're taking you out snap snap snap
I wish one of them was my kid I would
call him up and be like if you ever do
that to a teacher again I'm gonna stop
paying for your tuition just snap into
the phone you don't talk to your
teachers like that alright [ __ ] is wrong
with you I don't know how the [ __ ] did
he end up outside
was he walking out to his car and they
all just surrounded him like the [ __ ]
Manson Family with Brad Pitt did
something put a knife into his [ __ ]
tire and why what happened the guy
couldn't get out of there where where
was [ __ ] campus security I don't know
the whole thing was [ __ ] weird you
know what's the worst is that is that
it's filmed and someday all of those
kids are gonna grow up and then they're
gonna see that and their kids are gonna
see it them surrounding this teacher
who's trying to be a good guy and no
matter what he says no matter how much
he apologizes they just treat keep
treating him like an [ __ ] and then
snapping their fingers and they like
film themselves doing it I don't
understand I guess that's being young I
think you know you're at that age we're
gonna change the world man you know
which is a good attitude to have I mean
short of cornering your [ __ ] teacher
they were talking to that guy like they
had survived the plane crash you know
and then there's always that selfish guy
that eats more than his share and help
isn't on the
yet you know there's always that one
selfish police they always used to have
that in those [ __ ] movies they were
talking to him like he was he was like
that I mean I don't know what I'll tell
you right now you could not do that when
I was a college student I want to do a
gig at Yale guys can you book me there I
want to do a gig and you guys boo me up
no don't boo me just snap after every
joke no I could never do a gig at Yale
those people are too smart they
understand the world beyond their
professors I mean this is just different
level uh
human beings and evidently we need to
listen to them oh my god that's the guy
from the guardian angels Jesus Christ
remember that guy the guardian angels
way back in the day there was a thing
when there was like too much gang
violence and all of this type of [ __ ]
and people didn't feel protected this
guy the guardian angels he decided that
he was going to have a gang of people
that just help people that weren't in a
gang and I gotta tell you the balls that
it took to be in that thing walking down
the street with that [ __ ] beret
when you came in there and rather than
you know this gang gets along with this
gang but doesn't get along with that
gang no gang got along with you
this guy had the [ __ ] balls in the
heart I mean I don't know how much it
worked out or whatever but you got to
give it up to him for trying
I remember just hearing stories about
those guys fighting other [ __ ] gangs
and [ __ ] Jesus Christ you know how often
can you get into a fight you into a
fight I mean yeah that's it
even in boxing right those guys fight
for a living they have a fight that
there's like you can't you can't have
another fight until you know I don't
know how long after that three months
for once six months something like that
[ __ ] guys had to fight every single
night I'll tell you after one night I'd
be like hey man I don't want to wait I
don't want to wear this beret anymore
bad enough gonna walk around with the
[ __ ] red nose goddamn day of my life
people thinking I'm [ __ ] booze and
I'm stoned sober I'm just getting my ass
kicked every night and not to mention I
don't look good in red okay so anyways I
don't know what honestly somebody have
somebody sent me that [ __ ] video and
I started to watch it I was just I
didn't get upset I just was just baffled
I just I don't understand people that
when they call somebody out on something
and then the guys going like other
person's like okay I see what you're
saying I guess maybe I did that because
I'm not good at remembering names they
just weren't having any of it
I don't know holy [ __ ] is that guy
[ __ ] old that guy that died sorry I
got like the New York sports channel on
here that guy who [ __ ] dances at the
Rangers game every time after every time
they score a gold Danson Larry or
something like that
[ __ ] you know I notice that old I am
though when I was doing the history
hyenas they had the picture of me in the
background you know from the the still
from the special and it was right over
Chris's shoulder and I just you know
every time we talked Chris looking at
him and then would glance at my face and
then back at Chris who's in the prime of
his [ __ ] life and then look at me
over the hill you know like that lion
that's gonna be challenged any day and
[ __ ] lose send off into the
wilderness to get run down by some
hyenas look at that goes right back to
the podcast maybe that's what that was I
don't know when I was just like [ __ ] I'm
old anyway
college kids Jesus Christ what do you do
what are you doing to your professors
huh what are you doing told surrounding
them on the [ __ ] school grounds
having an inquisition and no matter what
they say it's not good enough come on
that's the kind of behavior I expected
Harvard see that you got a
divide-and-conquer I'm sure they're
listening right now just being like you
know sports aren't everything man
everything is everything I honestly I
don't I don't know maybe this is just
part of getting old I guess everything
[ __ ] changes cuz I can't imagine like
grandparents look at in my generation we
would listen to the [ __ ] devil music
allegedly they went from Benny Goodman
and [ __ ] moonlight serenade I don't
[ __ ] on to the apple tree with anyone
else but me right then by the time I
generation camera you're [ __ ] crazy
Oh child what the [ __ ] happened these
kids so I guess this is the next level
least they're not doing crack man
alright hang in there Yale I'm sure it's
really hard to be going to an Ivy League
[ __ ] school that the whole world
respects I just hope when you get out of
there you could somehow find a job man
good luck to you
alright that's the podcast
have a great weekend you [ __ ] and you
know if you meet somebody from Yale make
sure you remember that name because that
is the most important thing in the world
all right go [ __ ] yourself so I'll see
you on Monday go Pat's
alright Dollar Shave Club do the [ __ ]
you know Dollar Shave Club has spent
years developing crafting refining all
of their products they have basically
everything you need for a mate for an
amazing shave now the starter wife with
such [ __ ] promise come on Phil the
executive razor the shave blada prep
scrub and post shave do gross and as
amazing as their shave stuff is Dollar
Shave Club is way more than just razors
Dollar Shave Club has you covered from
head to toe they have everything you
need to shower shave value Hey
brush your teeth and yes even wipe your
butt to all the shave club can keep you
automatically stopped up stocked up on
products you use you get what you want
whenever you need it whether that's once
a month or a few times a year as a
Dollar Shave Club member you'll never
have to waste time at the store
wondering if what you're getting is any
good you'll know what you're getting is
the highest quality and right now you
can put the quality of Dollar Shave
club's product to the test their
ultimate shave status set has basically
everything you need for an amazing shave
the executive razor dr. Cobb is easy
shaper prep scrub and the post shave do
the best part is you can try it for just
five bucks after that they reached the
restock box shifts regular size products
at regular prices get your unlimited
status set for just $5 at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / endo cheeto talk
about how good men look when their suits
fit well oh I just love how it cups
their bowls makes me want to buy with
this sellin if you know what I mean
Indochina Chino is the world's largest
made-to-measure men's brand they make
suits shirts coats and more and
everything is made to your exact
measurements for a great fit you get to
personalize all the details including
your lapel lining and your own monogram
they have hundreds of suit options for
all occasions including work formal
events and even your own wedding the
best part is that they are affordable
almost all their custom clothing is
under 400 bucks u.s. the process is
simple choose your fabric pick your
customizations and submit your
measurements they're handsome your
package will be delivered straight to
your door in two weeks you can get
measured you can get measured and design
your suits at your nearest endo Chino
showroom or China you know China or do
it all yourself online in indochina comm
start your style upgrade with now with
$30 off your total purchases of three
[ __ ] man they make this copy way more
difficult than my brain work
to start your style upgrade now with $30
off your total purchase of $399 or more
at endo chino calm you get 30 bucks off
if you spend more than $40 399 bucks I
think I wasn't trying to say when you
enter burr at checkout plus shipping is
free that's in day just before the bucks
it should be free it cuts the Indochina
comm promo code burr bu are are for $30
off your total purchases of $399 or more
an incredible deal for a made-to-measure
clothing you really have no excuse
anymore to wear clothing that doesn't
fit well god damn it it's butcher box
when it comes to me quality matters
there's more to two within the texture
and the taste
not everyone has convenient access to
hack while it inmate luckily there's
butcher box put your bucks believes that
everyone deserves high-quality humanely
Thor's to me that always felt safe
butcher box is a no-brainer it's the
best meat shipped right to your door
which means one less trip to the grocery
store grocers I don't know options like
100% breasted and finished beef
free-range organic chicken my favorite
heritage breed pork wild they just said
heritage fork know what m to the breed
wild caught Alaskan salmon and sugar /
nitrate free bacon it's Wade it's the
way meat should be what your bucks is
the most affordable and convenient way
to get healthy humanely raised me right
now put your box is offering new members
ground beef for life that's 2 pounds of
ground beef in every box for the life of
their subscription plus $20 off their
first box just go to butcher bucks calm
slash burn or enter the promo code at
checkout that's butcher box calm slash /
or enter promo code burr at checkout and
lastly but not leastly it's fields
everybody do you experience stress or
have anxiety or chronic pain does your
butt itch nothing didn't see it or have
trouble sleeping at least once a week
you're not alone many of us do
personally in your own words please
discuss the issues you have and how it
kept you from living
your best life every day well I [ __ ]
flip out and screaming people I didn't
see that in the first few sentences you
make me feel annoyed scared that's how
you make me feel so that's that's my own
personal life what are we doing here I
was searching for anything that would
help was I then I discovered feels did I
who wrote this copy what is feels I
don't know feels his premium CBD
delivered directly to your doorstep
I know these [ __ ] this stuff's
good what this feels do yeah you know
what I mean it feels like you put
wintergreen gum on your shoulder and all
of a sudden you have third-base coach
again waving them around feels naturally
helps reduce stress anxiety pain and
sleeplessness
please talk about the condition you have
and how taking fields is healthy I just
told you my shoulders [ __ ] up now I
feel like a third-base coach that's not
true I still go to work some of the gunk
out here but it feels better feels like
I poured like [ __ ] Listerine on my
shoulder yeah no more bad shoulder
breath easy to take place a few drops of
feels under your tongue oh I was doing
the roll on one and feel the difference
within minutes
I got trying to [ __ ] real human support
new to CBD no I use the [ __ ] chick
Roland I got to get this stuff though
feels offers a free CBD hotline and text
message to support to help guide your
personal experience feel better
naturally feels works naturally to help
you feel better there's no high hangover
or addiction join the fields community
to get feels delivered to your door
every month you'll save money on every
order and you can pause or cancel
anytime this is great for all those
nagging pains that you have and actually
rather than just numbing it it actually
helps to heal it that's why it's called
feels is that what I'm supposed to say
feels has me feeling my best every day
so I can live my best life and it can
help you to become a member today by
going to feels calm slash burger and you
get 50% off your first order with free
shipping that feels a tal s.com slash /
I'm going to do this because I got to
get more of this [ __ ] to become a member
and get 50% automatically taken off your
first order with free shipping feels
calm / permian right it's like barfi you
are I'm sorry
I wasn't listening to you as already
looking at the next question you know
what before I came in here I was reading
about adult ADHD because you know I like
to read it every couple months and like
make you take a quiz just to confirm the
facts bring it in here that's like in
fact I'll take the quiz right now have
adult ADHD should I go get it I'll take
it and I'll answer the next one I'm
gonna [ __ ] destroy this test you know
she's out of the room you know I'm gonna
destroy it I'm just gonna [ __ ] lie
and never let the broad in your life
psycho [ __ ] analyze you all right
whether you want it or not they're
already gonna be running around in your
head you don't need to [ __ ] open the
door you know what I'm saying
but here in a relationship with a woman
remember that Star Trek one where they
[ __ ] tied those guys hands behind the
back and they stuck that worm and their
[ __ ] helmets and then put it on they
went in their ear that's what I'm
talking about
now let me take this [ __ ] test here
here we go all right ready this is all
that I have to study the whole thing is
the whole thing is never rarely
sometimes often okay that's how you
answer is that the title of it no that's
how you answer you already failed that
sounds like a [ __ ] the name of a book
how often do you ever rarely see some
tension while doing something for work
school hobby or funnik activity eg
remaining focused during lectures like
too many [ __ ] things hobby fun
playing is the question good I'll just
pretend you have like power over me
often do you have difficulty sustaining
your attention while doing something for
work school a hobby or fun activity
never if you already know the answers
never rarely sometimes often often okay
how often are you easily distracted by
external stimuli like something in your
environment or unrelated thoughts what
to say it again about the joke can I
imitate Barbarina what are people gonna
get it oh my god I don't even need say I
don't even need to ask you psych
central.com
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] forget it then whatever
they say I am how often do you avoid
this light or are reluctant to engage in
tonight's evil spell psych si si
yes well I'm psyched and they spelled
with an S it's so gay dare you embarrass
me like this on my own [ __ ] podcast
sustained mental effort or thoughts
I actually didn't hear the first part
cuz it reminds me of other [ __ ] you
can't focus it doesn't mean to remind
you other [ __ ] bill the like the second
question was how often are you easily
distracted by external stimuli like
something in your environment or
unrelated thoughts that was question
number two bill often oh my god how
often do you have trouble listening to
someone even when they are speaking
directly to you like your mind is
somewhere else often it's not somewhere
else they're not interesting and I just
look at this shoes screw you you're
saying I'm not interesting no don't
[ __ ] do we can make it all about you
well I got a [ __ ] disease over here
often how often do you have difficulty
or in organizing a task or activity
needed to get done
eg poor time management fails to meet
deadlines difficulty managing sequential
tasks not one of those was good what I
thought what you said in the end with
the options I told you at the beginning
that it's never rarely sometimes or
often that's how you answer somewhere
between rarely and sometimes there's hey
I get [ __ ] done I'm a successful [ __ ]
guy that's true alright what why we say
sometimes ok how's that well you're not
supposed to say it I was supposed to say
wait we I apparently need to coach you
through this cuz you keep getting
distracted oh you are a devil woman in
this how often do you fail to give close
attention to details or make careless
mistakes and things such as schoolwork
at work during other activities rarely
you can take my work seriously ok
setting that [ __ ] writers room six
seven eight hours a day I don't have to
be there Chris showed up like the douche
a might be something that's I didn't is
that there how often do you forget to do
something you do all the time such as
missing an appointment or paying a bill
not all the [ __ ] time mm-hmm
not paying a bill though I pay bills yes
you do
yeah but the important [ __ ] near the
important [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] locked and
loaded
output sometimes all the dumb [ __ ] how
often do you lose misplace or damaged
something that's necessary in order to
get things done your phone.i glasses
paperwork wallet keys etc do I lose it
or damaged it wouldn't mean damaged it
throw it how often do you lose misplace
or damaged either 100 [ __ ] time yes
how often do you have trouble following
through on instructions or failing to
finish schoolwork chores or duties in
the workplace eg you started to ask but
quickly lose focus and are easily
sidetracked sometimes but not that much
I'm really good with the work thing do
you yeah no I would agree with that
obviously you are there's no doubt that
you are successful what is what is the
end game of this so then you find out
have [ __ ] ADHD [ __ ] whatever and
then what I lose the argument about the
[ __ ] closet downstairs how often are
you unable to play or engage in
leisurely activities quietly how often
are you unable
today or engage in leisurely activities
quietly well I mean cigar smoking is
pretty quiet I love doing that sometimes
rarely okay really
how often do you have difficulty waiting
your turn such as while waiting in line
what's this man in large let's go know
if I see a long line I just like I just
think about what is it really worth
standing in line is this you know
imperative to my [ __ ] survival I
don't need it I'm out often however you
feel like you're on the go acting as if
you're driven by a motor eg you're
unable to be or uncomfortable being Saul
for extended beyond alright alright I
see with a restaurant or a meeting nah I
like going to restaurants bill at the
end of a meal right well you are still
finishing dessert you literally have
your coat on a you have your credit card
out you're holding it on the table like
looking around I know cuz that's because
of the [ __ ] small talk throughout all
of it oh oh here's a story people tell
story you know this one you know it's
stories bombing if in the middle of you
have to go so Dan [ __ ] isn't grabbing
their coat sometimes I'll put how often
do you leave your seat and often do you
leave your see in situations when
remaining seat is expected temp ends on
whether I'm being energy paying your
place in the office or workplace if I'm
being entertained sometimes okay yeah I
have a hot [ __ ] you know how often do
you blurt out an answer before a
question has been completed
eg completed another print sentence or
can't wait your turn in conversation to
aunt Oh an answer like I know the answer
cuz that doesn't happen because I don't
know the answer how often do you blurt
out an answer never D fleeted jeopardy a
wheel of fortune never happen that's
that's I'm gonna putting often and you
know what's often can I put often hey
you do whatever you want this is [ __ ]
test isn't gonna affect my life in any
way you know what your point is how
often do you feel restless like you want
to get out and do
something yeah like I get up and during
the day I want to do something yeah I
want to lay around like a douche so yeah
often how often do you fidget with or
tap your hands or feet or soar how many
more it's the same [ __ ] question over
and over and over again how often do you
fidget or tap or squirming your seat I
don't know sometimes okay how often do
you find yourself talking excessively
Safa how often do you find yourself
talking often sometimes I'm running my
mouth all the [ __ ] times other times
I clam up like when I'm at a party I
don't walk in and take it over I see
everybody daddy baby I'm talking about
their [ __ ] I'm just lazes awful the
corner I don't say anything okay
sometimes how often do you interrupt or
intrude on others such as budding into
their conversation or taking over what
others are doing well I was with it
until the end taking over it's a little
[ __ ] hard letting in or taking over
yeah this is all the same [ __ ]
question over and over again see a
patient non ADHD person will be able to
take this quiz and like you know what
this is just great all right it's almost
done we're several of the symptoms
present prior to age 12 know you never
felt this way as a little boy okay no no
I didn't all right
the [ __ ] was I worried about do these
symptoms appear in at least two or more
settings at home and school or home and
work or whatever uh yeah all right your
score it's just 20 questions you scored
a total of 42 based upon your responses
to this adult adda th screening quiz you
ever applied in a way similar to peach
people who have symptoms of moderate to
severe attention deficit disorder
moderate to severe that's a severe
that's pretty much the entire gamut oh
there you go psych calm you may have it
a little bit or severe all of that
mental torture do you see why I tap out
half the time
symptoms typically worsen in situations
that requires you just Center up that
mention or mental effort or that are
boring you know that was written by
boring people that are tired of getting
interrupted by exciting people everybody
go [ __ ] yourself don't [ __ ] see what
you just did you drag me through my own
[ __ ] there they go but I love you hey
just look at this right here this is
this is the guy I worked with the other
day Brad Carter oh right there
you remember him right look at this
picture right there gradually do oh yeah
[ __ ] he was awesome yeah I'm gonna post
a video he had he had he's got a video
on the internet says man plays guitar
while having brain surgery and it's him
black says they were they were in I'll
let him tell the [ __ ] story every
sound dumb enough as it is but uh
[ __ ] uh that's cool amazing [ __ ]
actor funniest [ __ ] hell and like can
be scary if he wants to be some I'm
really looking out for this guy to do
big [ __ ] man all right that's the Monday
morning podcast everybody good luck with
your holiday shopping and good luck if
your [ __ ] wife comes in and goes if
you want to take a test because I can
tell you right now she is a [ __ ] axe
to grind and you're gonna fail it
you